♪ ♪
The mighty Baba Voss.
A fearless warrior
in a world without sight.
Everyone close to you
always ends up suffering.
Now it's your turn, brother.
I swore I would never
return here.
Edo took my daughter.
♪ She would never say
where she came from ♪
I'm going to find out
where he's hiding her.
♪ Yesterday don't matter
if it's gone ♪
What do you see?
A shift in the world.
♪ Goodbye Ruby Tuesday ♪
We are chosen to usher
in a new world.
I carry within me a child
born with God's gift of vision.
[shouting]
Sight will return,
and the first nation
to harness its powers
will dominate the world.
You're declaring war
on the greatest military force
in the world.
This is not our fight!
If we walk away,
thousands of people will die.
[grunting]
I know this enemy.
I was this enemy!
They fight to enslave!
We fight for freedom!
I say we open our gate
right now...
...and welcome them to hell.
[cheering]
There are weapons more powerful
than swords.
They won't defeat our future.
Welcome home, Baba.
♪ Goodbye, Ruby Tuesday ♪